hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i am
sitting today with jamie wheel who
is the founder of the flow genome
project he is the author
of stealing fire and his newest book
recapture the rapture
jamie welcome my friend how are you
fantastic man and as you said as as good
as we can be all things considered
as good as we can be all things
considered which in light of the topic
of your
most recent book is a heavily qualified
statement but we will
we will get there um i should probably
say
uh upfront a couple things
i have not fully read your book i
haven't had it long
enough to do that i have however
used the time with your book as well as
i can
i have perused all the way across it and
i am blown away
by what you appear to have done i am
looking forward to delving into it
completely
and i am also looking forward to uh
discussing the content of the book with
you today even though
um there will be things that i have i
have missed in my perusing
um in general i have a kind of
arms-length relationship
with uh books that i'm
often kind of reluctant to talk about
because intellectuals tend
to have a kind of reverence for books
that um causes them to cast suspicion on
anyone who expresses
doubt but my sense is that as much as
there's a lot of positivity
obviously conveyed through books there
is also a downside to them
which is that when you have read a book
you take in the author's perspective and
it is often
hard to restore your mind to the
configuration it had before you did that
and so
there's a downside with your book i'm
not worried about this
because you do such a fantastic uh
job of effectively documenting your own
mindset
and uh leading people through
the the things you want them to discover
so my sense is
it is a very different kind of book and
although i haven't fully read it i
highly recommend
that others do and i'm sure i'll be
returning to it after i have read it
oh thank you and you know i think you
and i um
share i mean we we've come up as
educators and
you know one of the sort of sacrosanct
ethical commitments is you know is the
somewhat cliche
teaching people how to think not what to
think and so not only is that
you know a stake in the ground which is
the intention is to
increase the quality of our discourse
and our reflections
and our decisions um but then there's
also just what's going on right now
and and you know and pretty much anybody
that i look up to
and turn to in the fields of
neuroscience psychology sociology
politics climate biology
the the closer they are to experts the
less certain they are of anything
you know in general just as an
epistemological stance based on the
humility of
deep exposure to the complexities
nuances
and contradictions and then we uh you
know
obviously well i wouldn't say obviously
we are perhaps uh
and arguably in a world of increasing
intersecting compounding and conflicting
exponential
curves so the mapping and modeling of
that
can only ever be provisional yes and
all certainty is probably our biggest
bane right now um
i would agree false certainty is a huge
problem and if i can
uh see if i understand what you just
said because
of the uh number of
let's say diatic relationships between
concepts which seems to be growing at an
exponential rate we are effectively
rescuing what we think we know with the
equivalent of epicycles and
we are in some sense like ptolemaic like
the little loops in the loops
right exactly and we are in effect
waiting for what will certainly be a
radical simplification
of what we understand that in effect
what we understand is becoming more
complex because we are having to
integrate more things with it and when
we can
figure out where to stand to look at it
it will probably not be
massively complex it will be uh simpler
and more intuitive but
having not found that place yet um
we have to deal with skepticism with the
complexity that we're forced
to deal with which as you point out
results in people who
who see this problem being uh more
cautious rather than more certain
yeah i mean and i have no idea i mean to
your point about kind of the synthesis
on the other side right
um i'd love to test this with you
but it seems to me that you know we are
hard-coded
for binaries for either ores you know at
the root level of you know electron spin
up down you know single cell organisms
like life death or food foe you know um
black white
you know good bad you name it and you
know it's what aristotle
called the law of the excluded middle
it's literally the foundation of the
scientific method which is which is
force binaries and and obviously anybody
who's you know remotely thoughtful from
philosophers to theologians to
physicists
have been like well actually it's it's
actually less and
less about i mean obviously contrast
either ores is a very effective way of
sorting the world
sorting the universe but it does hollow
out
the shades of grey if you're just going
for black and white
and so that move from contrast
either or friend foe to context
it is situational it is dependent it is
nuanced like that
feels like a potential lens that we
could apply
to good effect because right i mean it's
just it's hegel 101 it's like
all dialectics all the time you know and
whether it's progressive conservative
whether you know
w whether it's you know technological
utopianism or ecological collapse it's
like it it's all happening
and it all depends so context and really
being
willing and able to be much more precise
in our locations in our
epistemic locations in our
intersubjective relating
all of these things it feels like we can
just deal with a healthy dose
of more provisional contextualism
so yeah i would i would
alter that slightly i think which is to
say that these dichotomies are tools
and there is a degree to which they are
illuminating
and for each of them there is a point at
which they
are uh more confusing than helpful
and you know the ideal mind figures out
how to use the tool to its uh
degree of constructiveness and then to
abandon it at the inflection point
and obviously you can't do a perfect job
because it takes some
uh time to discover that the tool has uh
uh become
unhelpful but nonetheless that's that's
the uh the objective of the exercise is
to figure out
not whether some uh some phenomenon is
binary or isn't but it is to say
to the extent that we look at it as
binary what do we learn and then at what
point
are we blinding ourselves with that very
same
uh insight and you know some things are
binary the closer you get to
um the uh the fundamentals the more
things you know it's either an electron
or it isn't
right it's hard to be nuanced about it
um or actually maybe i've picked a bad
example because of the sum over
history's
uh understanding that even an electron
is in some sense a cloud of
probabilities but
um but nonetheless uh an electron isn't
a proton right it's a it's a fair binary
um but when you get into complex systems
each
each phenomenon is impacted by so many
other things
that there's always uh cause for nuance
um even when a binary may tell the bulk
of the story
yeah absolutely i mean it's waves and
particles and which is the
which is the helpful lens for the task
at hand
right okay so how to
bring the audience into a discussion
of your book let me first say
i would say that your book is
in a genre that
is new
and growing um it is part of an older
tradition
there's obviously as you point out in in
the initial part of your book
um a a long tradition of people being
concerned about
the direction we are headed and uh what
its implication is for the
the immediate future much of that
thinking not being very productive
but your book uh and you
feel free to correct me if i'm uh
misportraying it but your book
diagnoses a uh a dangerous trajectory
that humanity
is on at the present attempts to dissect
the nature of the problem it uh
describes tools that might be
productively
wielded and then proposes a direction
that
you believe we should head and so in
some sense um
it is in the genre that i would say
is books about potential game b
solutions to the failures of
of game a uh is that fair or do you feel
that i'm dragging you into a milieu that
uh isn't isn't yours
well i mean you know on a pure branding
thing i would have thought that you know
the the existing meme of bringing your a
game
we we would have wanted the good thing
we were trying to get to to be game a
but aside from that um my sense is
i mean this is my my academic background
i mean i i went into
i thought i was going to be an
elbow-patched you know
wood paneled professor i was all done on
my phd coursework by the age of 22 and
it was in historical anthropology
and so and then just kept learning kept
growing realized that you know the
tempting of academia i was like oh
whoa maybe that's not the hap i thought
i just had like one more year to gut it
out and then it was just
you know smoking a pipe and thinking
thinking thoughts and then i got
disabused of that
um but for me the area of inquiry is is
kind of
janus facing you know so it looks
backwards and forwards
and looking backwards is a kind of
hybrid discipline of neuro-anthropology
you like you look at humans you're like
what are these curious customs we
you know we hominids seem to and deploy
and
what is happening today and are there
precedence
to that can we look back through the
ethnographic through the historical
record and see where else have we done
things similar
and the kind of neat hybrid these days
is that we also have
neuroscientific information we have site
you know psychology and study we have
biology we have all of these things that
we can then bring to bear of
why do the things we do socially and
culturally as tribal primates why do
they work
and then once you can understand the
sort of the lego blocks
of that then you can look forward into
culture architecture so now we
understand we've got we've got
case studies we've got evidence and
we've got basically kind of
a pattern language we see how these
things tend to go together and how they
tend to work
and then we can say now if we're going
to build or innovate
or architect new versions of how
we gather then might we do that with a
little bit more skill
because we know the pieces and their
functionality so to me it's neuro
anthropology looking backwards
culture architecture looking forwards
and
if you wanted to kind of distill this
book into its essence it's an attempt
to create an open source operating
system
for transformational
and anti-fragile consciousness and
culture so what's the linux
for the future you know and and really
standing by that which is it's not like
that any top-down solutions no matter
how idealistic or noble
tend to degrade to fascism over time
and we really i mean i just take it as
an article of faith but i think there's
lots of case studies to support this
that we are actually smarter better and
more resilient
the closer we are to our own unique
conditions so
localized and adaptive responses
honoring
specific cultures life waves value
systems et cetera like we're better
bottoms up than we are tops down
but everybody building a spaceship in
their driveway
it doesn't work either it's a complex
hard thing so can we share
like linux here's here's source code it
shoots straight
it tends to spit out answers that are
more or less congruent with the original
conditions
and then you can modify it you can adapt
it you can mutate it
and then if your modification works
better
great because other people will you know
other people will then adopt it it'll
propagate
like we don't know we need to we need a
a million
solutions and 999 000 are probably going
to go tits up
but but if we can accelerate and harness
and sort of scaffold and support
heightened human innovation and the
realm of architecting
functional civilization in society then
maybe we have a chance maybe we have a
way forward all right
um i still i want to
drill down on this a little farther
though because when i say game b
i am unfortunately invoking an entity an
organization
a group of people who met and i don't
mean to what i mean
to say is that game b has become
a label for
a category of thought if you take
all of those of us who are part of the
living cohort of humanity
some small number of us have recognized
that actually
you don't need to understand with
precision where we are headed to
recognize that the trajectory
itself will be fatal short term
and that that requires some architecture
to find our way out i would add
evolutionarily that we're very good
humans are at figuring out what to do in
circumstances where our ancestral wisdom
has come apart but that our modern
version of this puzzle
is unlike any past version in the sense
that the tools we would typically bring
to bear to figure out what to do next
won't work we cannot evolve our way out
of the situation
by having certain groups
extinct in the attempt to discover a way
out and just figuring
you know working from whatever uh subset
functions in some sense humanity is all
in it together this time
and so your book i read is a very
deliberate
attempt to describe what i would say
you tell me if you differ but to
describe
a crisis that we have uh found ourselves
in
and to map as you say an open source uh
architecture for
basically bootstrapping our way out and
um
yeah is that that fair yeah and i mean
you know and to be very clear right
there's there's a thousand things wrong
screwy
scary consequential that are happening
um
so and i just chose to focus on what
felt like
an under discussed and an underdeveloped
missing link in that discussion of our
meta crisis which
was you know that everything is going
exponential
for good and bad except for meaning
except for our ability to make sense and
then decide what to do about it
and that you know to your game a game b
notion i mean if we take
everything that's kind of we've been
living and is in the historic
record as game a i think you could
actually tease that apart even
and say that you know meaning 1.0 which
is
almost all of human civilization and
history
up until really even sort of the last
century you can you know you can
timestamp it back to the french
enlightenment whatever but like up until
super super recently
meaning 1.0 was almost always analogous
or synonymous with
organized religion and communities of
practice
and obviously we have seen the erosion
of that and that starts with
things like the rational empirical
scientific revolution french
enlightenment nietzsche's god is dead
but also more recently you know pew
research foundation finding
the collapse of allegiance and
affiliation less than 50
of americans now for the first time ever
don't align or orient
to any kind of institutional community
of practice or faith
um the nuns the n-o-n-es are the fastest
and largest growing
you know denomination in america you're
like wow okay that's
novel and then throw in catholic church
scandals the erosion of trust you know
everything so you could just say that
edifice is collapsing
um and at the same time meaning 2.0
which you could make the case is sort of
modern liberalism
right again the sort of you know
democracy and alienable rights of
citizens civil rights market-based
economics that
whole bundled package um that's you know
tech lately sometimes called sort of
late stage capitalism well clearly
the last year the last four or five
years has really been
eroding our trust and faith in those
institutions as well
and meaning 1.0 was it offered the
promise of salvation
but at the cost of exclusion like if you
believed you were saved if you didn't
you were damned more or less kind of
around the world right if you were among
the elect
you got in to the good life and modern
liberalism you know coming out of the
you know the religious wars of europe
you know through the middle ages to you
know to to
the enlightenment was like whoa okay we
need to that that that way lies ruin and
bloodshed
so we're gonna offer we're gonna try
something else we're gonna offer
inclusion
right all men and women are created you
know are entitled to life liberty in the
pursuit of happiness regardless of race
color or cree
right wonderful notion you know partial
execution but
that was that was the reverse promise
instead of offering salvation
at the price of inclusion it offered
inclusion
at the price of salvation separation of
church and state god is dead no one's
going to tell you what it means
so the question for kind of the game b
move is is what does meaning
3.0 look like because we're clearly in a
meaningful crisis
and the absence of those two pillars has
created this
hollowed-out vacuum in the middle and
rather than us
all sort of doing what christopher
hitchens and richard dawkins and
young sam harris might have said as the
new atheist you know like god is dead
get rid of superstitious strongmen and
angry sky gods stand on our own two feet
and become rational materialists and do
the secular humanist thing
better we're not seeing that right we're
seeing this
you know in that vacuum we're seeing
people getting shunted
to extremes of fundamentalism and that
can be doubling down on traditional
fixed religious beliefs but it can also
be scientific fundamentalism it can it
can be ideologies it can be anything of
like with extreme certainties of
worldview and
and sort of manikin good and bads or
if you're not bought into one of those
then nihilism
you know none of this matters burn it
all down diseases of despair addiction
depression suicide
so the question is is how do we rebuild
you know how do we pop the long pole
back in the tent
that can shelter us and provide
community
and pre and weather the storm with
meaning 3.0
which would be can we do both can we
take the best of both can we create
inclusive salvation is that actually a
thing we can even hope for
and then how would we do that in a
decentralized
open source way so that we're not just
replacing one ism
with the next one yeah um
in a sense i'm wondering if it's
fair to say that we are in a meaning
recession i mean almost that it in
effect
we had achieved a kind of meaning the
scientific materialism has been
marvelously productive
in describing a great many things that
are true
and useful enough to build with
but it has actually created the crisis
as well
um and that what i'm seeing and what you
describe
i think you memorably say early in your
book um
that it's a moment at which you would
expect us to be at our best but we are
at our worst i'm sure i'm just
paraphrasing there but
um yeah i i see this as well and i i
uh i'm almost stunned by the degree
to which every counterintuitive thing of
value is being
uninvented right we are
um we are losing confidence in
many of the most important uh
innovations that we've made
and it's resulting in a kind of uh
it's like the worst of both worlds not
only
is it um
faith-based and metaphorical right
meaning that you cannot infer from it
directly
but it also has not stood the test of
time and so
what we're getting are uh beliefs that
sound good are very frequently
wrong and are unfalsifiable by virtue of
the fact that we have
thrown out the good part of the
scientific materialism
which was uh the robustness of our
ability to test what's true
yeah and and you know to your point
about sort of right when we should be at
our
at our best and this happened you know
this time last year right with with the
um dawning realization of a global
pandemic
there was a number everyone was kind of
looking for reference points and and
certainly
fdr churchill world war ii like became a
familiar theme like okay it's one of
those is it really one of those i think
it might be
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself and church chills you know never
ever ever give up and victory gardens
and keep calm and carry on we kind of
got
ready to do that and i think people were
ready for some leadership to potentially
ring that bell
and and get us in line we were kind of
digging back into our cultural memory of
like okay i think it's one of these
times
and instead we ended up with the most
batshit
upside down factionalism schizoid
denialism and just
just we warped and i mean if this was
our dry run we just
failed badly you know and and
my my senses is that and and yours and
heather's work i'm
directly informed and inspired my
thinking on this which is where you
you had made the case probably a couple
of years ago now
um of hey folks be careful like you know
if
we we either are required to step into a
global perspective
or we're going to regress under stress
and we're going to go back to tribalism
of any strife it could be ethnotribalism
but it could be ideological tribalism
you know and especially the internet
you know you can find your corner in
your pocket and your people no matter
how wacky
right and and you made the case of like
hey be really careful
friends and neighbors if you play the
tribal identity card because it's so
deeply ingrained
in our biological social tribal primate
structuring and you know you look at
the you know neurochemistry of belonging
molly crockett who was at oxford and
she's now at yale you know has done some
really neat work on that she's studied
everything from
positive versions of tribalism like the
burning man experience to
negative versions like political rallies
and those kind of things and you know
and it's when we experience an erosion
of certainty trust and status you know
our dopamine and serotonin levels
plummet we start becoming
less altruistic more prone to being edgy
or to lash out
when we get together in groups our
dopamine levels spike
but that actually creates um a decline
in hyper altruism so we basically you
know it's like somebody being coked up
at apology you basically just become a
self-absorbed muscle
you know and then the super spooky and
sometimes
counter-intuitive one for people is is
you know the role of oxytocin and that
in pop you know culture it always gets
that moniker of like the
the cuddle drug or the trust hormone or
the love hormone and you're like well
it's also
the curb stomp your neighbor it's the
ethnocentric tribal like yes it bombs
mother to child
and lover lover and and owner to pet you
know to dog and those kind of like all
those
groovy things but it also massively
increases the likelihood of you being
willing and wanting to other the other
with extreme prejudice
and and so you know this sort of like
tribalism is destiny
and humanism is optional
and to me that that's a conversation
that
i'm not sure we're having with enough
urgency
because we we see the extremes on both
the left and the right and
they would swear that they are enemies
of each other
but if you pop up a level and you're
like well what are what's actually going
on
what are their truth claims and what are
they trying to bring about
in most instances it is a dismantling of
the current system
which holds and again however idealistic
however partially delivered upon it has
nonetheless been the ideals we've
rallied around
in times of crisis from the getting you
know the battlefield of gettysburg to
you know and and lincoln to the
rubble of 911 and george bush to
obama and the charlottesville shootings
you know like
time and again we've been like okay to
to
martin luther king you know in
washington in 63.
we've been like hey there's this
beautiful
thought experiment the infinite game
right let's include everybody in it and
let's have this
humanistic project and and at the times
of crisis we've
dusted it off and we've recommitted to
it but there's been a shift there's been
a
seismic shift in the last decade and
in intensifying in the last five and
then again in this last one
of nah [ __ ] it we're breaking that
treaty we're not even pretending
that we're trying to get everybody on
the bus we're blowing up the bus
and and i'm sure you've come across this
study i just found it
so singularly representative of this but
it was a it was a
university in australia that studied 500
americans in with
across the political spectrum including
alt-right identitarians
radical social justice activists and
then somewhat sort of centrist
moderates and they assess them against
dark triad personality so you know
sociopathy machiavellianism
gnosticism and then also
authoritarianism
and the moderates in the middle who had
their own belief systems but also
extended
the right for other people to hold those
so kind of just pluralism
they didn't score on any of those four
qualities but
both sides of the far political spectrum
did
so they basically were like you know bad
actors regardless of what flag they're
flying
increasing the factionalism and so you
know if you use that james cost notion
of finite and infinite gains which
most folks are familiar with like finite
games win lose up down tribalism 101
an infinite game win win bring as many
people into the game
and play the game for as long as you
possibly can right
we're actually seeing you know the fact
that these sworn enemies
are actually on the same team they're on
team finite game and what's at stake is
that
versus the infinite game and and this is
right you know i'm curious as to your
thoughts on it but
my senses is that in our grief
in our frustration in our rage to
satisfaction
anger at the bill of goods
that we have collectively been sold
right
there that temptation to burn down
our society our civilization our value
sets
risks destroying this
tender fragile incredibly precious
human experiment of the infinite game
and
and you know the ropes be i think
roachbeard cod carrying
you know one of the originators of
sociopaths
right hijacking liberty equality and
brotherhood that was a french revolution
was pretty badass to start with
you know but he said if you want to make
an omelette you got to break a few eggs
and the finite gamers to your
evolutionary thesis
all they've got to do is poke
pride and provoke other people to other
each other including themselves
and they win they win it's like darth
vader being like strike me down man just
strike me down in anger and i've won
versus the infinite game which is like
trying to put humpty together again it's
like
magnifying glasses and super glue and
tweezers it is
it is asymmetric meme warfare because
all the finite game
bad actors of any and all stripes have
the second law of thermodynamics
and right and humanists don't and i
don't
feel like in the in the in the
discussion in the public sphere we
almost think like may the best meme win
this is a
contest of of equal ideas and it's not
it's lopsided as all ghetto
yeah it couldn't be more lopsided i was
going to bring up entropy myself
um but yes and this i think goes exactly
to the
the point i was trying to make about the
space of the small number of people who
um have clearly seen that some game b is
necessary because game b
is about to blow up among the reasons
that it's about to blow up
has to do with the asymmetry in power of
those who wish
to take apart past games how the
failure of recognition of how fragile
what we've accomplished
is right so to me as an evolutionist
there is no uh conflict whatsoever
between
the observation that our society is very
powerful and generates a tremendous
amount of wealth and the observation
that it is
almost impossibly fragile right those
two things are completely compatible
and so uh yes with all of our
confirmation bias and heuristics that
make it hard for us to wrap our head
around
hard for us to wrap our head around and
as you point out in your book
uh the pax americana has now dominated
enough generations that there's this
sort of sense that things just
go on this way and that's really the
exception rather than
the rule but people don't intuit it
because they have no personal experience
with
uh it coming apart i also quite resonate
with your point about uh the last year
having been a test that we have
failed spectacularly and that that is an
indication of just
uh how urgent it is that we start
thinking differently
about solution making
all of it does however make me want to
address something which i know is there
because the last time i saw you in
person which i guess would have been in
austin where you live am i right
uh in austin in 2018 would have been
well could have been yeah in any case um
we had that nice lunch
yes we had that nice lunch and i it
began to
dawn on me that um
you and i are on parallel missions
because of exactly the recognition that
we were just talking about
i think we're built a very uh
compatible but very different stuff in
some ways and
it uh it occurred to me in talking to
you
how um how can i put this
how deeply troubled
you are by humanity's predicament
right and i felt that looking at your
book
as well right i i think you know i
there's a part of me and you tell me if
i'm projecting something onto you that
isn't there
but there is a story that people need to
understand
in order to figure out what it is we
have to do
and what sorts of tools would have to be
brought to bear for it to work
um and then there's also this watching
the clock run out right and these two
things are in conflict can
can people be brought up to speed or can
enough people be brought up to speed
fast enough that the clock doesn't rot
out on us
and i see you being very patient
about that and very thorough but you
also acknowledge right up front
um that many things in the book really
uh under circumstances where there was
more time
would need a further exploration but
uh just in order to sketch the bare
bones you're forced to
to just get right to it um so
in any case have i have i described you
at all in terms of
your sense of uh the urgency and
how you feel oh my gosh yeah i mean look
you know
as i said i mean i mean one of the
subfields that i concentrated in
in historical anthropology was i mean it
was kind of guns gems and steel
meets sapiens so it was fundamentally
clash of civilizations
what are vibrant resilient cultures
especially i was
fascinated with proto-contact like like
the notion of like
and then the cavalry came and then all
the indians were removed to reservations
like the tragic
end game interested me less than
dialing back the clock to when it was
still a fair fight and you could
really more hopefully more accurately
read viability and resilience of given
different cultures radically different
cultures so like 300 years of the
iroquois confederacy
totally you know leading the french and
english into sugar
blind territory and gaming them
brilliantly you know
or anything like that right but at the
same time was also an assess
a a lane of environmental history and so
you know uh donald worster who famously
wrote rivers of empire was just like
here's hydraulic societies right from
egypt to the mormons you know to the
anasazi like this is what happens when
you
irrigate for your food folks you know
and here's the case studies and so you
know and then you know you're looking at
the oglala aquifer and
the great plains and how we're siphoning
that to pump water or the fact that 40
of the irrigation you know or that
they're they've built tunnels
from the eastern sierra to feed l.a and
that by the time someone in beverly
hills gets a drink out of their faucet
it's been
peed excreted and purified and recycled
nine times from the snowmelt
you know and that forty percent of the
water that gets shipped in open air
aqueducts to vegas
evaporates and you're like oh [ __ ]
friends this doesn't pencil out it may
not be this year it may not be
next decade but it sure as [ __ ] is not a
sustainable run
so so that like staring into that
particular abyss was something that
happened to me in my
early 20s and it just made me a lousy
cocktail party guest um
you know well yeah no no
well i don't know may i didn't know you
in that phase maybe you were a lousy
cocktail party guest i
i rather doubt it um
my guess is the party changed um
uh at the point that you deployed this
kind of understanding but
um i i didn't mean to interrupt you but
i i do want to parse this out a little
bit further yeah
the what you're describing
this doesn't pencil out was the the
phrase you ended on
right i have my own version of this
right i call it uh
it needs a better term but it's the
theory of close calls that basically
you can deduce where you are with
respect to hazards by figuring out how
many close calls
you've encountered right they describe a
curve
and part of that curve is unsurvivable
and so you know if you're if you've had
three near misses
for a serious traffic accident in the
last year probably there's something
wrong with your driving
it's not guaranteed but but you can tell
and so
when i look at just the list of serious
uh disasters that we've faced in the
last
uh decade for example or if we go back a
little bit further you know we've had
the financial collapse of 2008 we've had
the triple meltdown at fukushima we've
had the elizo canyon
leak uh of natural gas
we've had uh the deepwater horizon
uh leak in the gulf etc in other words
we've got this list of close calls all
of which were survivable but they tell
us something about the magnitude of
hazards that we're playing with
and we can infer the rest of the curve
you know we can infer from fukushima
that a much worse accident could have
happened orders of magnitude worse
why didn't it we got lucky none of the
full fuel pools
cracked right during these explosions
but they could have there was it wasn't
like
being clever prevented it from happening
we just got lucky right so
you don't want to be dependent on luck
for your survival
right you never want that to happen to
the extent you can avoid it
and we're there yeah we're so there and
i think i just read an article in the
last
few weeks uh that was just basically
talking about that like we actually may
have been sailing way closer to the wind
than we ever imagined because we've just
got perpetual
accumulated survivor bias like
right we've like the largest meteor
crater we've ever mapped is like a mile
across because if there'd been one
that's three miles across we wouldn't be
here to map it
you know and like all of those kind of
things like everybody in the nba
you know playing basketball must make
you tall you know it's the correlation
causation things but
the idea that like how many tight spots
have we
just ducked to even be here in the first
place
and is that a sign of our brilliance or
success or is it just
utterly random statistics right that
have delivered us
to this point and you know it's it's a
little bit of a combination
right like we do get clever um but
too late and we far too often uh
end up persisting out of out of luck um
i will say that the
upshot of the theory of close calls when
one deploys it personally is that when
you detect that something you're doing
is resulting in luck being the reason
that you made it through
you should treat each instance as if it
had gone the other way
right if you step off the curb and you
are not struck by a car
the the inference you should take is not
well i must be doing something right
because i wasn't hit
the inference is actually i did
everything necessary to be hit by a car
and the fact that i wasn't hit by a car
is immaterial that was the luck part
so i should alter my behavior radically
rather than
very little in in as a consequence of
this observation
but if i can head back to the question
of what
what drives you
and actually i did want to contrast it
what i suspect
is distinct is that you
are driven
by the emotional
horror of allowing what is happening to
humanity to unfold
without doing everything in your power
to prevent it and i must say i think
everybody in this sort of game b space
has to have some mechanism for dealing
with the recognition of where we're
headed because
it really uh is so
um appalling really the needlessness of
it
right as you point out the uh the
vulnerability of the infinite game and
the
likelihood that fools will be allowed to
drive us
into the reinvention of a finite uh
human game is so
is so uh tragic
in my case i think i
i proceed from the recognition in fact i
say sometimes
that um i know of no
reason that we
are too late to save ourselves i believe
saving ourselves is still possible
but i'll bet against us i'll do
everything in my power to make sure
we don't screw this up but if i had to
guess what happens next
we miss the opportunity right now
why do i say that right for one thing
that tends to demotivate a certain
number of people
right on the other hand there is
something necessary in order to
play around in the space of solution
making
one has to um or maybe one doesn't have
to maybe
maybe the point i'm getting at is that
uh i find one of the things that's most
fascinating about you is how
close to that emotional um
motivation you are right i have to find
distance from it in order to think about
these things
um and it's it's a natural way for me to
approach it
and i see you as almost doing the
opposite the opposite trick which is
staring directly into the abyss and kind
of keeping an eye on it in order
to keep you going am i off in left field
here
well i mean you know
i i'm only like whatever i i'm a mutant
that doesn't have perspective on
what is you know um
totally boring or unique about my own
lived experience i think i mean i just
worked on the naive assumption that
everybody kind of thought and thought
things and saw things the way i did
um but my my life was always split
between
academic study like fascinated about the
deep cuts and and the research but then
also
direct experience and you know of the
most raw
alive living i could possibly do you
know you and heather do
have done amazing stuff down in the
rainforest like experiential learning
was the thing i was
always passionate about so like
mountaineering guiding and so
by both professional training but also
by disposition i probably sought this
out i feel like
i'm always scouting scouting ahead of
the group
to figure out what's next what's around
the bend where's the next
crux like the hard thing we have to
prepare for where's the next resource
water campsite whatever it would be
and shuttle running into the future to
try and
try and map and spot that so that the
rest of the party the rest of the group
has a chance of making it to the
to that place and and
you know i mean i even end the book like
on the one hand this was i mean hey
this was completely and it still might
just blow up and destroy my career
writing this book
it's the most ridiculous grab every
single like tap dance through the
minefield
you know god sex death and rapture
ideologies in a world that's lost its
mind
let's bundle them all together talk
about them all and hope it goes well
right you forgot about you forgot about
the psychedelics
yeah yeah yeah yes drug sex god death
and the end of the world what could
possibly go wrong
and you know and and there goes my core
you know my corporate speaking career
if i ever had one right so but on the
other hand i feel i felt like i couldn't
not
and the the inspiration i took was
something along the lines of like the
svalzbad
seed bank you know up in scandinavia
like hey what are all these heirloom
seeds can we
put them in a vault because we might
need them later
um or even like the irish monasteries
that you know they had the um
pound sets like the re-skinned
parchments but they would write and then
overwrite because it was so precious
for their lumen manuscripts and then
they ended up randomly
being this hidden treasure trove of some
of the ancient greek writings that then
got
rediscovered and kind of kicked off the
italian renaissance
and that whole neoplatonic revival which
kind of gave us the seeds of you know
the enlightenment in
us today so in the writing of the book
and the attempting to make it an
open source toolkit i was like i have no
idea how this is going to land i could
go over like a ton of bricks in 2021
but is this potentially a little manual
where somebody someplace could use to
reboot vibrant thriving healthy
pro-social
culture and that's kind of what i had
that was my commitment it was sort of
bhagavad-gita
you know like you're not going to get
what you want but you got to do it
anyway
so stack up and make up you know yeah
well
all right that's interesting um in my
darker moments i have wondered if
um i mean i'm not a believer in
fate or anything like it but if my
obligation isn't to try to document what
happened here
um because it would be too hard to stop
it now
it's a it's a thought i keep control of
and i shunt it away to keep
myself going on the test so so wait so
say that say that again i
wanna you know to me it looks like this
i don't i know that we
or i think i know that we could save
ourselves and actually what we produce
now
could be we could deliver on the promise
of the civilization that hasn't quite
worked that we are presently
participants in
but i don't expect us to do it because
as you point out i see us getting dumber
rather than smarter which you know that
could be the adaptive valley it could be
the darkness before the dawn but there's
a really good chance it's not
which means that
well either what happened here will be
invisible to everyone else in the
universe permanently
right maybe we just joined the the
silent
majority of the fermi paradox uh
or somebody happens by
and they look at the ruins of planet
earth
and they say what happened here and i
don't think there's a good description
for them to find
and that's sad because the lesson of it
might be
for them to be able to save their
civilization right a space-faring
uh creature would have a lot to lose
maybe they
wouldn't be space-faring at this level
if they hadn't figured it out already so
maybe there's nothing for them to learn
from us but
i do wonder if the obligation isn't in
some sense to just
create something that says all right
let's describe in game theoretic terms
what happened here and why something
that didn't have to end came crashing
down
right and then where do you leave it
right what do you write it in do you
write it in bakelite that's a very
durable substance where do you leave it
but anyway
this is this is uh this is my dark side
and i
uh i keep it at bay by basically
imagining uh that we're
we're one headed for a waterfall
and we're one to have a very low chance
of being able to paddle fast enough
to get out of the pole of the waterfall
there's still no point at which your
chance is
so low that it makes sense to stop
paddling
right so you know basically my sense is
yeah let's paddle like hell let's see if
we can
do something surprising here um and that
is not
uh it is not an emotional thought for me
right it's just like well logically
speaking what else are you gonna do
right let's see if we can turn
this around so you know that's how i get
there and
what i'm trying to uh tease apart here
is that i have the sense that this looks
very different from inside your skull
and yes i recognize the problem of
it being very hard to regard oneself
because
our experience is so dominated by uh
our own consciousness and it's very hard
to step outside it but
um what is it like
for you to confront um
the peril of all of humanity and
everything that has ever been
simultaneously as you clearly do
all that you touch and all that you see
and i'll let you lie back borrow and
steal and everything under the sun is in
tune
right um yeah that but the sun is
eclipsed by the moon
yeah yes there's no dark side of the
moon maybe it's all
dark right so yeah like right so so i i
mean i track you
right and and i and i think that um
[Music]
you know you mentioned game theory and
and certainly we have
lots of friends that are you know deep
in that world and and
map and model um many of those
permutations and outcomes
and generally when i speak to them i end
up soul-crushed
and in the fetal position for several
days afterwards like literally like very
rarely do i have a
actual visceral reaction to
conversations and there's times where i
feel
queasy i feel like puking i feel like
literally running away
um and and um and it occurred to me and
i mean i'm
this this is this is you know this is a
um
helpful fiction i'm willing to sign on
for myself i'm not certain
but in the same way that you know like
like the whole
field of behavioral economics that you
know kahneman
thaler dubner levitt the economics guys
like popularized which was
hey homo economicus the idea of a
rational individual
making trade-offs and always making the
best self-interested decision that's a
total
fiction that's [ __ ] we are freaky
contradictory
you know moody we we're just fickle
people
and that isn't that more interesting and
in the realm of
game theoretics it feels like we've
almost got homo machiavelli's
what is the self-interested cynical son
of a [ __ ] who's always going to do this
shitty thing multipolar traps you name
it
right and and to me there is
something i do you know to your point
about how many near misses have we had
and all that kind of stuff you could
look at the cold war like we should have
blown each other up a thousand times and
there's that russian dude in the sub who
just didn't push the button there were
so many near-misses there were
computer glitches somehow we didn't
and i feel like even if it's just an
article of faith we don't we don't hold
it up as a law of nature or physics
right we just say
hey leave space for grace
leave space for grace like do any does
any of this stuff
pencil out actually
but shy of just slitting our wrists now
and being done with it
can we leave space for grace and to me
yes it rhymes and it's kind of a neat
concept but like if you look at
history that's what has always happened
like the moments that history has turned
right those cusps have been when
someone unleashes this
asymmetric force multiplier of
humanity and you know gandhi called it
sachigrah he called it truth force
right howard thurman the
african-american mystic
brought it back to the states rebranded
it soul
force his his mentee mlk
then socialize that in 63 and as i have
a dream speech where you can meet the
majestic heights of physical
force with soul force right nancy keene
at harvard business school you know
wrote that book forged in crisis it was
dietrich von bonhoff for the lutheran
pastor who tried to assassinate hitler
it was rachel carson
silent spring abe lincoln frederick
douglass um
and one other and it was basically what
i found so badass about her book
was it wasn't hagiographies it wasn't
like these retrospective like look at
these heroes that did this thing she
went into their letters and their
correspondence
what was actually going through their
heads at these moments these cusps
and it was no idea what we're doing we
just
have to try something we're going to
just lob a hail mary and
fingers crossed this works out like the
emancipation proclamation like every kid
gets that in grade school in high school
and college
ad infinitum he lincoln was at his wits
end
he had zero he was despondent and had
no confidence like to your point i
wouldn't bet against us like he was he
he hadn't he wasn't that
this was going to change the civil war
or win for the union or
libya you know or create a multicultural
post-racial society nothing
he was he was out of bullets this was
his last one
and so that to me is the premise of this
whole book which is not
just a plea for courage and curiosity
and connection but a hopefully a toolkit
like don't it's absolutely inadequate to
just kind of scrunch up our uh you know
eyes and wish for it like we actually
have to go do it
and and if we can then can we unlock
that force multiplier that space for
grace is
us it's not ufos it's not baby jesus you
know it's
us showing up and and doing
the impossible because there's nothing
there's no other option
boy well this is great uh it does
um effectively establish
the the point i was uh searching for
here
um that you are sometimes reduced to
what you describe as a fetal position
by discussion with others who have
looked into the abyss is effectively
um the thing i was wondering about
i will say i
this i don't know why i'm obsessed with
this but i do think
figuring out what the various
motivational structures are that cause
people to show up for
this kind of work is key because if in
effect we are looking for
the others um and i will say
i never end up well i've been in a fetal
position but only as a fetus
you know only when i had to
right everything dude just not a lot of
space but um
anyway i mean i don't recall it that
well but uh
in any case my sense is look
i guess i just want you to look through
my eyes for a second and then i want to
look through yours
and uh figure out what we can learn
through this
um i know with
i believe near perfect certainty that
nothing i do
could possibly matter in the long term
right and i could just
keep pushing this out right chances that
anybody remembers me
500 years after my death pretty low
chances if i beat that one that
humanity survives another thousand years
pretty low
right chances if we figure our way
through
the peril that uh we
survive to have to figure out what to do
when uh
our galaxy collides with the andromeda
galaxy
pretty low even if we defeat all the
puzzles
ultimately there's something at the end
of the universe heat death or whatever
right this is all going every species
that has ever been
will go extinct including mine no matter
which way you calculate it it is
impossible for anything ultimately to
matter
right so that's a terrible thing
that there's the screaming abyss yeah
but it's not actually no
no no no it to me it is the opposite
right the fact is i believe in things
even though i know those facts to be
true
right yes well yeah and i would call
that a transcendental existentialism
like let's not dress this up you know
lipstick on the pig whistle past the
graveyard take your pick like let's just
acknowledge the bare facts and yet
there are still things we choose but not
even and yet
right this is the this is the part i'm
having trouble articulating
once you recognize that there ultimately
is no mechanism to save ourselves
then there's a question about well what
should we do and one response i suppose
would be
hedonism right i find that abhorrent but
i can imagine somebody
getting there from from that conclusion
but to me
my sense is okay we now have to scale
back what it is we're trying to
accomplish
right if we can't escape the heat death
of the universe or whatever
stands in its place then what can we do
and one thing that i think we can do
which strikes me as
a practical
scale of goal is to recognize
that even though i'm aware of the
futility i'm glad to be alive
right i like it um i'm glad my children
are alive and my wife and i'm glad to be
talking to you and this was all very
nice and the question is
doesn't that result in a moral
obligation
to deliver the possibility of having
such a life to as many human beings as
we can possibly arrange
which does not mean living
simultaneously it means
how many generations can we make the
human experiment
continue and how can we make those
humans who live
as liberated as possible to pursue
meaning that
seems to me like the moral obligation of
what we currently understand about our
predicament in the universe
and uh i like that project
even though i know it's not durable
right i know
it's ontology
right you're you're like hey we don't
need to gussy this up
just the idea of holy [ __ ] we're alive i
mean that there's a there was a great
um postcard i i sorry you know
it's become an instagram meme but it was
basically just had a little
a little kid sitting on a crescent moon
you know dangling his feet kind of thing
and it said
we're in space no one knows what's going
on
i love you there it is
right here it is it's you know i used to
think something like this
thought uh as a child which was
you know imagine that what we were
wasn't capable of recognizing that there
were others
right imagine that you were a kind of
being that just
didn't have the sensory apparatus to
even know that you know
that there were others right and what a
profoundly lonely thought that is
the very fact that we have the ability
to like
not only know that there are others but
to exchange
abstract ideas to talk about values to
come to agreement on things this is such
a
a marvelous kind of creature to be and
we take it for granted and we ignore it
and we treat it
badly you know it's like somebody's
given us a marvelous car and we go
you know do donuts in the parking lot
rather than
honor the gift or something um
so yeah
i guess the point would be this let's
say that we take
uh the argument i've made for the
futility of everything we will do
and we scale it back to the human
dimension right so that's humanity
ultimately will be a temporary and
futile exercise
we could say the same thing about each
of us as individuals right
now i could read it
right but i could react to the fact that
i
know that i'm going to die and that
everything i
my whole mental apparatus is going to
come apart i could respond to that
by staying inside and trying to purge
every hazard
right and preserve it as long as i can
or i could say screw it all right i know
i'm gonna die done
um i'm gonna use i'm gonna actually
gamble
with that recognition i'm going to take
it as as liberating rather than stifling
and um you know i hear i hear this
in your writing and what you say when
you speak
very differently you know you have a
kind of
rather than just embracing the futility
of it and taking
license you have an elaborate
schema for categorizing the values
of life and anyway it's it's fascinating
to me because
i think it ends up in the same place
through an entirely different route
it feels like that and and you know my
long-term
partner and good friend julie well
she'll often just laugh at me
because like i will like map things out
to infinity and back and i'll be like
would be good idea to pat shoulder
now of your friend and apply physical
touches like really you could have just
loved me you know and i've had to like
solve differential equations
to the back and beyond so yeah there's
some just part of me that just kind of
sees things in zeros and ones and
schematics and
and ways forward but ultimately it's
super simple it's the oliver wendell
holmes thing of you know i i don't
give a damn for the simplicity on this
side of complexity but i give my life
for the simplicity on the other side and
and i actually
i think that there's a there's quite a
bit in the existential risk game b
clever people bucket you know where
there's an awful lot of wallowing and
thrashing around in the complexity
and the idea that the solution to that
complexity is even more scintillating
and brilliant complexity
um but i think i think right i i think
at some point just [ __ ] get like like
physics trump's metaphysics friends like
it doesn't matter whether you're a
libertarian
whether you're a doom and gloom or
whether you're a c-stetter whether
you're a psychedelic
renaissance or a blockchain infused like
we're just going to be running smack dab
into
physics increasingly and the and the
best laid planes of mice and men and the
memiest
thought leaders are just gonna their
their theories are just gonna be running
onto the rocks of reality
so let's just keep our eyes peeled but
to to your point i mean i think that um
just to unpack that bhagavad-gita thing
like that like that idea of
how do we maintain being passionately
committed
to our pa to play without being attached
to our cherished outcomes right and and
in some respects
it's you know admiral jim stockdale that
famous stockdale paradox he was the
highest ranking pow in vietnam
he found out he was in there for like
nine years in a north you know in a viet
cong prison
not friendly and he noticed that all the
pessimists who became pows died
no surprise but he also knows that the
optimist did too
and that was because they would be like
oh the boys will be home for christmas
or easter or july the 4th and when those
milestones came and went
they collapsed and gabe literally gave
up the ghost so that the stockdale
paradox kind of got encoded as
be ruthlessly realistic about short-term
reality
and in infinitely optimistic
about possible outcomes and and to me
and and so
so and in fact our buddy zack stein
right uh he you know
however trained theorist educator uh
psychologist you know
generally i think open-hearted wise dude
he hipped me to a model that i you know
i haven't been able to
get out of my head since he shed it but
it's the you may be familiar with this
it's a kabbalistic notion of
three phases of basically human maturity
or insolment and it's the pre-tragic
the tragic and the post-tragic
and the pre-tragic is you know i
anybody can go out to be president or an
astronaut i'm going to find my prince
charming or my sleeping beauty
right my my life is well and that could
be
as brief as literally what you said the
fetal position in the womb and then i
get
spat out of a birth canal into a whole
harsh cold life and it's scary and i
didn't opt for this
or it can be all the way through chasing
all the brass rings the academic success
internships professional thing i'm a
partner at mckinsey or my law firm or
i'm a tenured professor i got all the
rings
like you know and i and i stay
pre-tragic but
invariably life will drop us to our
knees
and disease illness despair relation to
heartbreak bankruptcy you name it
like the physicides of life happen and
we enter the tragic
and most folks get trapped there or
crushed there
but there is that far rarer and precious
move to the post-tragic
and if we can do that right and and if
we can do that then we have a chance
that's kind of where soul force that's
that's where satyagraha lives
it's not in the denial or the solving or
the transcending
of the tragic nature of this human
experience but it's in the deep embrace
and then the getting back up anyway
move yeah all right sweet
because so there's this uh
i haven't deployed it in a way that um
it has had any impact in my field other
than to
generate a small amount of mockery but
um the my field
misses a fact about
evolution that is so
transformative that in some sense i
think we're just waiting to grapple with
it and
the idea is that effectively
lineage is a
selectable evolutionary
target that selection cares about
something that i would call lineage and
all evolutionists know this at small
enough scale we all understand
kin selection but the fact that this
scales up
arbitrarily
what do you mean when you say that the
arbitrary scaling uh what i mean
is kin selection doesn't stop at some
degree of unrelatedness
that is to say
there is a calculation a kin selection
calculation that we are not capable of
doing on paper
but that we could discover the calculus
for
and having done so we would understand a
lot about human history that we
are so far scratching our heads over
with
respect to evolution and in short you
know you don't need the calculus to
infer the meaning of lineage lineage is
very simple
which is to say you and i and every
other individual
is wired to see and care about things at
a certain distance
not because that's the limit of what
matters but because that is the limit of
our likely influence
or at least would have been for our
ancestors right an ancestor
who cared about um things a hundred
generations later would have been
wasting their time because they had no
influence on what would happen a hundred
generations later
right seven might be the limit or
something like that but it doesn't mean
that what happens 100 generations later
is immaterial it just means it's
inaccessible
so in essence what you are suggesting
the embrace of the futility
is a i think a tighter
more metaphorical encapsulation of a
truth that is hard for us to speak
a truth that exists in the physics
actually
um but that we don't yet have the
language to say
right which is to say that the
ephemeralness of our life
is actually immaterial to what we are
built for we are built
for lineage we are built to the extent
that our actions have an implication
on where our genes are a hundred
generations from now we should care
very deeply about it even if we're not
wired
to care right so we have to we have to
hack the architecture
in order to correct for our vast power
because we now do have
um tremendous power over whether there
are any people on this planet
a hundred years from now or not right we
have that influence
so yeah so in in any case
it is always it ought to be true
that deep belief systems speak
metaphorically
about things that should we care to
we can recover analytically right that
we can
do the math and discover that something
that
we say actually maps onto some real
thing
in some way that ought to shape our
belief systems and our values
and our behavior and i think that's what
i think that's what you're describing in
effect
well i mean you know because i i agree i
mean i often say especially
if you notice this at least i've noticed
this especially in the kind of
progressive
left side with a touch of new age
spirituality and that kind of stuff
there will be people who when faced with
the current matter crisis
will then go all kind of fuzzy and
dissociate into indefinite time frames
and they'll be like oh well maybe this
is the kali yuga or maybe you know like
forests burned down to create new shoots
and you're like yeah they do and it's
going to suck for us
you know and basically if it's outside
my lifetime in the lifetime of my
children it's effectively academic
like it doesn't impact my short-term
survival planning which is
which is what i need but the opposite
thing you were saying which is kind of
expanding our frame of past present
future
ancestors and descendants right there's
a lot of
fascinating research that actually shows
that we become more resilient
when doing that so like children who are
aware of intergenerational
family stories they do better on test
scores they're less susceptible to
depression and suicide they are
literally more resilient it's almost
like having a little
short wheelbase jeep going down the road
with stiff suspension bouncing along
it's just
me atomized rational individual and
every success or failure or setback is
mine and mine alone and i feel it fully
versus the long stretch limo of you know
my grandparents and my children and
their children
and and it smooths out the ride
and right and we are literally more
resourceful and
another just beautiful piece that from
from some of that research was that
and actually the euro part of her family
and our families the best
actually inoculated less well it was it
was a poorer buffer
than we're a family we've been at this
for a while we've had our shares of ups
and downs
and we're still here and so right that
kind of just
blended reality and it and i haven't
this is not a fully baked thought but
i'd love to run it past you which is
my sense is that you know obviously back
in indigenous times and even into
traditional
agrarian times with high fixity of place
you know most people never ventured
further than 50 miles from their
birthplace
what you're you know i'm millage son the
son of miller's son son of miller's son
what do we do we run the mill
you know and like what is our faith it's
the faith that we grew up in and there's
that synagogue church or mosque and this
is just who we are where we are doing
what we do
and so even then identity was somewhat
smeared
intergenerationally right and deeply
bound
to place and then we end up with hyper
atomized rational individual consumer
consciousness especially you know into
the 20th and 21st century
and that can't take the hits because if
i don't get
mine from me now i'm bent
right i i collapse and and actually i
i end the book funnily enough with like
okay
most of the book is my best effort at
fixing this and then
the the end which my editor did not want
me to write
but i couldn't in good consciousness i
was like hey guys here's the deal
we might do every we might get we might
do everything we possibly can
and still not make it and back to the
stockdale paradox the boys are going to
be home
for christmas right we actually if we
really want to talk about
what is a an anti-fragile a durable
perspective on what's going on and what
do we do now
it has to be able to survive crushing
disappointment and setback otherwise
it's not a durable
philosophy or way forward and jonathan
lear at the university of chicago
wrote a book called radical hope and it
was actually a study of late 19th
century
um plains indians removal to
reservations
and he said he said the ability the
inability of a civilization to conceive
of its own demise is the blind spot
of most societies right he said he said
but radical hope isn't
isn't waiting for the ship to write
itself it's not
oh we're in a piece you know we're in a
spotted we're not we're in a rough seas
but then there's
you know there's going to be palm trees
you know in white sand beaches it's
it's an abandoning of hope
of bargaining hope and but the
maintenance
right of a belief that at some
indefinite point in the future in a way
we cannot conceive of
from here there is resolution and it is
worth us putting our back into it now
right and to me that one feels about
right and if you look at
communities from the roma to the kurds
to the tibetans to the ashkenazi take
any perpetually dispossessed peoples
right they've always had that it's it's
the moses to canaan it's 40 [ __ ]
years in the desert friends
and i might not even get there i mean
you know mlk said that on the night
before you were shot
you know i may not get there with you
right but we're going to keep on
striving and i feel like
there's not in a retroromantic way but i
feel like there's absolutely some
vital re-extension and connection of our
self-sense of our identity of what's in
it for me
is actually what's in it for us everyone
everywhere everyone
not just me now because the just me now
is is probably going to get increasingly
gritty
for a while this is this is uh perfect
actually um and i i have uh
sometimes said that i'm very troubled by
the idea
of the jews being god's chosen people
but i do like the idea that we're
god's anti-fragile people and that the
idea is
you know a perpetually dispossessed
minority population
it's improbable that such a thing would
survive as long as we have and so
there's some kind of wisdom in um the
recognition of how one even thinks about
the puzzle and it does not
involve a obsessive focus on
self and whether i'm getting mine right
it has to do there is this more
inclusive
lineage phenomenon um
and you know i think almost anyone
almost any decent person
can find the
um the basis for this kind of thinking
because
i mean uh this this will be the easiest
of exercises for you but if you consider
the question about how you feel about
your family's well-being
should something happen to you tomorrow
right it doesn't change your sense at
all
of the importance of what happens to
them your presence or you know
yes you'd like to be there and frankly
if i put it in the context of my own
uh my own life if something happens to
me it will be a terrible setback
to my family but it doesn't change
the degree to which i care about them
and one can imagine a narcissistic
person thinking well
yeah i'd like my family to be happy for
lots of reasons while i'm here and then
as soon as i'm gone it's not my problem
right that's a terrible person so
the recognition that whatever
life is can't possibly be about
the individual right the individual
comes to an end and
is ephemeral life is clearly when it is
done right
about something more durable than that
and the point i'm trying to make is that
the degree to which we lose sight of the
importance
generations down the road is an accident
of evolutionary history
evolution uh should have programmed us
to see very you know should have
programmed a buddhist approach
rather than one that was so heavily
based in the practical
that we have the myopia of our ancestors
who had no influence over
things a century down the road
yeah i mean yeah we could have done the
bodhisattva commitment
everyone everywhere everyone and instead
we all got our own personal jesus
you know and and you know tim wu the the
columbia law professor net neutrality
you know that
that that stuff he wrote a fascinating
book called the attention merchants
and it's all about the history of
marketing basically and how
like i think four of the
foundational these seminal early 20th
century marketers were all
failed preachers and you end up with
this absolute porting over of like
original sin kicked out of the garden
you've got chronic halitosis or acne or
or an embarrassingly dirty kitchen floor
whatever it would be and
here is your hockey stick redemption
promise if you and now redemption is via
purchase and
consumption right and the more we
fragment
and atomize and valorize and
and and sort of steroidally boost your
rational fragmented egoic identity
as the source of all salvation and
possibility
the more the more we've create we've
created like hyper kinetic little
marbles pinballing around but we haven't
created
coherence and cultural resilience and
buffering
right that is arguably a key piece
of what we need going forward yeah
that's very good and it also explains in
some sense
why we seem to be
accelerating in our vulnerability
to these game theoretic failures
where the the conflict between
well-being at the individual level and
well-being at a collective level
increasingly defaults to the individual
and sabotages
the collective which at one level makes
sense because
the individual is in a position to uh
betray the collective and another level
doesn't make sense because we all come
from lineages that manage not to do this
right and so the extent to which as we
become
more modern we become more vulnerable
to errors that our ancestors
even if they did not analytically know
how they were avoiding them
did manage to avoid is impressive so
i i take from your your point about the
increasing kinetics of the individual
marbles
driving the fate of the collective set
of marbles
i think it's a it's a point we should be
paying very close attention to
yeah i mean and that in some respects
that almost gets us into like the
tragedy the commons
right as well as game theoretics right
because the idea is if i am homo
machiavelli
if i am just that individual choice
maker based on
is you know basically instant
gratification seeking point
you know seeking pleasure and avoiding
pain i'm gonna do shitty things all the
time
and the notion of rooting in lineage
rooting in
culture that has some pro-social buffers
um
there was there was a fascinating book i
actually ended up coming across in grad
school it's called enchantment
and exploitation and it was a study like
this multi-century study of
northern new mexico mountain villages
right so harsh
limited resources right how did people
get along here and it was a contrast
between
mexican um sheepherd societies and then
the range wars right the basically
eastern capitalized
ranchers coming in and in the hispanic
communities there were built-in
shame structures from excess
accumulation
right so so if if one guy decided i'm
going to be the i'm going to be the
sheep baron
then his mother his grandparents his
uncles they would start razzing him like
hey
asshat what you doing you know like you
just drained the pond or you just
trampled the river or you just
overgrazed the posture that like the
rest of us were planning on using next
week
and there were there were checks and
balances and buffers against
asymmetric resource accumulation and
concentration
and then the range war dudes come in
again eastern capital let's go
you know five thousand head of steers
let's fence this you know instead of
usufruct
land rights of like which was the the
origins of the term indian giver
was the idea that you know westerners
would like sign on a piece of paper and
then expect
total and exclusive access to land and
then most indian trees were like no
we'll let you hunt here as well and we
won't kill you
like that was what we thought the
exchange was no one can own land what
are you talking about right
and right versus like barbed wire and
and shotguns
to protect and then and then seeing the
ecological impacts
when you have cultures that are broken
from
local buffering of resource allocation
and distribution into
just pure extraction smashing grabs
so like how do we do that in a
post-modern way
right that says hey don't be an asshat
we all live here yeah that's exactly it
and uh my favorite example of this is
uh salish prohibitions against
fishing more salmon than you can use
right but you'll find it in in you know
every ancient culture
that uh was local to resources that were
uh prone to overexploitation you know
this is
in large measure when eleanor ostrom uh
famously discovered about how basically
we do avoid tragedies of the commons
races to the bottom and every other form
of collective action problem
uh you know of course in the ancient
traditions it's all written in
metaphorically
and it you know it uh invokes uh
metaphysical forces that are not real
but they stand in for real
things um i i have argued it's
uh in the book that heather and i uh
will uh
it's going to emerge next fall um what
is it called what is it called
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
yeah um but we uh we have a chapter in
there on what i call the fourth frontier
and uh we talk about the
uh the maya and other temple building
societies and whether these temples
actually
are a buffering structure of exactly the
sort you're describing
that an obligation to you know i don't
know how much you know about mayan
temples
probably a lot but uh the mayan temples
are actually onion-like in the sense
that it's not like
somebody drew them out on a piece of
paper and or whatever they would have
drawn them on
and then built the thing but they
actually grow right so that they're you
know the temple starts out small and it
keeps getting larger
um and that effectively
um the investment in these temples and
the roads the sock bays that go between
these little city-states that is an
investment that did not turn
into more maya that needed to be fed
right so
in other words by modulating the
investment in these physical structures
our argument is uh they would take the
pressure off
of the civilization so that it was not
constantly at the edge you know a good
year would produce a higher population
and a bad year would cause conflict
the investment in these structures would
allow
uh modulation of the resource and
protect it which of course would then be
partially explanatory in how the maya
lasted so long
on fragile tropical soils
okay so this is a total tangent but
you're the guy i can ask so much so i'm
going to ask it right um
you familiar with david reich's work at
harvard all over genetics
right so so you know fascinating studies
of everything from neanderthals to homo
sapiens to
population of the americas and all this
kind of stuff um
and you know and just it just is what it
is right you do the
you do the dna analysis it tends not to
lie i mean you can have goofs in
measurement and decoding but like
that story trumps anybody's
philosophical or
theoretical explanations so it's
upending
you know a century of anthropology and
history
right sure um but so so talk to me
because like i mean you
yuva harari right among many others
and and sex at dawn chris ryan i was
just talking with him last week like
like there's a number of folks that are
these days it's become newly fashionable
to put a pin in the map at the beginning
of the agrarian revolution and say
that was the beginning of the fall that
was where we ended up with
excess work social inequities um
poorer nutrition et cetera et cetera et
cetera patriarchy you
you name it ownership property that was
the fault hunting and gathering was just
awesome and and that's where it went
tits up right
um and yet you know you look at the
genetic records
and whether it's that you know the the
tribes from the siberian steps
the indo-aryan basically that swept into
europe you're like
memetically they were fitter something
happened like we ended up with what we
ended up with through a series of
evolutionary and adaptive challenges
so what's your take what's yours and
heather's take on kind of
reconciling a a retro romantic look back
of saying that would you know that's
that was the fork in the road we should
have gone back to
versus well it it seems like it kind of
worked or they wouldn't have
replaced those populations or the memes
and the norms
wouldn't have perpetuated what how do
you
pass that yeah unfortunately we don't
have enough time to go deeply here maybe
we should
revisit it but in some sense this is
simple and the problem comes from trying
to infer
uh a a moral lesson
from these transitions i mean obviously
the agrarian revolution
allowed many more people to exist on the
same pieces of territory and it involved
surrendering a great deal of autonomy
and we can talk about
the uh the trade and whether it was
worth it and whether you'd prefer to be
a hunter-gatherer but
i think there's no question that at the
level of
effectiveness there's a reason that the
agrarians replaced the hunter-gatherers
overwhelmingly across
almost every landscape and that's
because
it worked but the problem is worked
doesn't mean what we would like it to
mean
right um and in essence the
the argument that we make at the end of
our book
and an argument that i will elaborate uh
in the future
is that we are wired for something
that is so mind-numbingly stupid
that no rational person could possibly
honor it our purpose the human purpose
is the same as every other species that
has ever evolved and it's just
barely worthy of comment on the other
hand
the machine bottom line it is it just
fornicate and die
not even fornicate it's just get your
genes as far into the future as you can
right one way to do that is to produce
lots of offspring
right it's not the only way but it's one
contributing factor but the point is
you don't want to have the same purpose
as a liver fluke right or
as coronavirus or any other creature out
there
that can't be much of a purpose if we
all share it right
on the other hand the tools that human
beings have been
granted by evolution in order to pursue
that purpose
are absolutely marvelous and capable
of um staggering accomplishment
insight compassion beauty all of the
best things about us
so it is time for our conscious minds
to sideline evolution's purpose
and to replace it with one that's worthy
of us that's readily doable the hard
part
is doing so in a way that does not
give an evolutionary advantage to those
who refuse to come along
right that's the question can we do that
and
uh we may have to leave it there but i
think there's uh
there's a lot to be said for recognizing
that our purpose is unworthy of us
and that we are finally capable of
articulating
a purpose that wouldn't be unworthy of
us it's time
well and then if i could just try tying
this up because because
in the end of the book i mentioned uh
the jesuit theologian tila deschaden
right and and and he was both a
paleontologist and
and a theologian he was banished by the
church after china
all of his books were suppressed until
after he died but he articulated this
and i think he wrote this back in the
20s or the 30s for the first time
but he said hey there's going to be
three intersecting curves
as we get as we get to the end times
right he's like there's going to be the
carrying capacity of the planet
there's going to be the people that are
drawn towards effectively the infinite
game
right everyone everywhere and there's
going to be people like you just said
refusing to play that game
and committing to smash and grab
tribalism he goes
and at the intersection of the
crisscross crash of those three
curves is the omega point and he said
and he said and at the same time giving
the whole event its significance and
meaning is
we don't know which way this is going to
play out but if we can get
there and we can get to the tipping
point then he says we will
like that we will engage in the process
of christogenesis like
literally the body of christ at the end
of time
isn't going to be a second coming it's
going to be an umpteenth coming
it's going to be all of us or none of us
to get to the omega point and that that
feels like i mean as far as a ripping
yawn
right like that feels like a a decent
story to try and live into
that's a beauty of a point and
interesting i i didn't know that point
and
interesting omega is a
an important term to heather and me we
have
used omega to signify something very
closely related to that
um which i assume is pure happenstance
here but uh
anyway i look forward to a conversation
in which we can explore that
question further because i i feel like
this is a
um a pause and not an end of this
conversation
um absolutely i have a commitment that i
have to go to
so jamie wheel it has been an absolute
pleasure
um i highly you don't have a copy of
your book there do you
that you could hold up um
somewhere i got in in 20 seconds i will
all right the book is recapture the
rapture
i highly recommend that people get a
copy and read it carefully
it's a pleasure to read it's beautifully
written um in addition today
full there it is look at that beautiful
godzilla nebula and everything
and and and recapture the rapture.com is
just where anybody can go there's a
whole
open source toolkit pdfs all the models
all the infographics kind of
you know lots of useful resources that
folks are interested to do
wonderful all right jamie uh i look
forward to our next conversation
and always good all right thanks for
joining us everybody
tuning in to the dark horse podcast
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you